Tea in this area started around 1924.
In Kenya as a whole,
we cultivate maybe roughly
about 160,000 hectares of tea
which produces I'd say about
350 metric tonnes a year.
That's why we are one of the largest
tea producers globally.
Second only to China,
Kenya is a major tea producer
where it's a vital and lucrative business.
and is one of the top
foreign exchange earners at 23%.
About 5 million people directly
and indirectly are supported
by the crop in Kenya.
And for about 650,000 people,
it's the backbone of their livelihoods.
But the country's dependence
on key foreign exports
hasn't always translated
into increased benefits
for smallholder tea farmers,
which make up the bulk of producers.
Most of the tea in Kenya
is smallholder farmers.
To have a factory you
require a lot of tea.
So for the smallholders who have small
ancestral pieces of property,
you need to take to tea
somewhere to be processed.
The small-scale farmers have
about 100,000 hectares of land
and they produce about 60%
of all the tea production.
The rest of 40% is held in larger farms,
which are owned now by the multinationals.
Think Unilever, James Finlay Williamson,
and Kapchorua Tea.
Though they make up the majority
of tea grown and exported in Kenya,
there's a push to establish
Kenyan tea on the global stage
as its own brand and identity.
What is picked exactly?
How does it work?
You look for one, which has got two leaves
and a bud, something like that.
That's what is picked.
And then it's thrown into the basket
as you see it being done.
Usually it's done by ladies and you can
see it's a continuous process, right?
So you have to continue
picking it because it grows.
And they are large workforce
because as you can see,
there's a lot to be picked
and then it's put into their baskets
and then that is what is weighed
and that's how they're paid for that.
Then it's transported to
the factory and also weighed
and sorted there in different grades
and then transformed into black tea.
That goes directly to the auction,
where it's bought by buyers.
Those buyers are buying on behalf
of various packaging companies.
So that's how they pack it into Lipton,
turns into PJ Tips into all that.
But we have a few local packers also.
Since the war in Ukraine, auction
prices for tea have been volatile,
and despite good weather helping
to increase higher production
export destinations saw sharp declines.
Former President Kenyatta emphasized
the need for farmers to increase
value-addition to 90% of the tea grown
instead of selling it raw.
We're not getting value as Kenyans
in this process and we need to get value.
We have to remove it
from the control of a few people.
All right, currently like now
it is controlled by Unilever.
It was the one which was having
all of these brands across the globe.
We want to be part of this.
So we also want to be producing
and also ultimately
packaging our own and
marketing our own tea.
In that way, we as Kenyans, become major
stakeholders in the value chain.
Once that happens, we can ensure
the growth of tea in the future.
Wainaina and Joseph are among the many
farmers in litigation against corporations
like Unilever to maintain
a better position within the supply chain.
Everybody is fighting
for their different rights.
Some of those in those farms
are fighting for historical injustices.
They want those farms to be re-allocated
to the local communities.
At the end of the day, all we are looking
for is fairness for the minorities,
so that we can all participate,
and enjoy the value of our tea plantation.